pour devrait tirer le bilan de ces
derniers mois très mouvementée il
devrait aussi évoquer les contours d'une
nouvelle ère promise par l'elysée les
français qui attendent de lui davantage
de liberté et une prise de parole sur
les dernières manifestations contre la
police un discours dans quelques minutes
et à risque
à deux semaines du feront tour des
municipales
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france édition
spéciale consacrée évidemment à
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron c'est à
20h précisément il devrait s'exprimer
sur les sujets prioritaires liées à la
crise sanitaire maintien ou pas des
zones oranges retour des enfants à
l'école
les français réclament davantage de
souplesse dans les restrictions imposées
jusqu'au 22 juin prochain théoriquement
un remaniement qui devrait être annoncée
par le chef de l'état au cours d'une
seconde allocution elle sera prévu entre
le 28 juin et le 14 juillet que faut-il
attendre de cette allocution dans
quelques minutes allocution de 19
minutes qui a été préalablement
enregistrées on en parle avec notre
reporter qui est justement à l'elysée
nadège abderrazak bonsoir nadège à quoi
faut-il s'attendre pour cette quatrième
prise de parole du chef de l'état
bah écoute et magali on doit s'attendre
à un discours qui doit détailler trois
axes de réflexion le premier le bilan
les perspectives du déconfinement le
deuxième les contours de ce que l'on
appelle le monde d'après et le troisième
les problématiques sociétales actuelles
marquées notamment par les
manifestations contre la racisme contre
les violences policières
emmanuel macron devrait tout d'abord
rendre hommage aux français pour leur
comportement durant le confinement et
après le déconfinement le président de
la république doit par ailleurs dressé
un bilan sur les forces et les
faiblesses ou de la gestion
gouvernementale de la crise liée choc
obid 19 au sujet de la phase iii du
déconfinement qui doit entrer en place
le 22 juin rien n'a encore filtré
en tout cas pas depuis vendredi et le
conseil de défense mise à part peut être
l'ouverture des frontières de l'union
européenne à partir du 15 juin ou encore
la levée des 14èmes dans les territoires
d'outre-mer emmanuel macron pourrait
aussi annoncer le passage de l'île de
france en zone verte un allègement du
protocole sanitaire dans les écoles ou
encore un calendrier pour l'éventuelle
autorisation à des rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes même si le conseil
d'état a devancé hier le président de la
république en interdisant justement
cette interdiction de manifester en
suspendant une tradition manifester pour
les rassemblements de plus donné
personne adhère tout de suite la
direction de l'elysée où le chef de
l'état va s'exprimer c'est donc la
quatrième fois que emmanuel macron prend
la parole françaises français
mes chers compatriotes je veux ce soir
vous parlez des jours qui viennent de
notre organisation face à l'épidémie
tirer les premières leçons de cette
crise est dessiné en quelques lignes
notre nouveau chemin à partir de demain
nous allons pouvoir tourner la page du
premier acte en quelque sorte de la
crise que nous venons de traverser
dès demain
tout le territoire à l'exception de
mayotte et de la guyane où le virus
circule encore activement tout le
territoire donc passera dans ce qu'il
est désormais convenu d'appeler la zone
verte ce qui permettra notamment une
reprise plus forte du travail et la
réouverture des cafés et restaurants en
ile de france
dès demain il sera à nouveau possible de
se déplacer entre les pays européens et
à partir du 1er juillet nous pourrons
nous rendre dans les états hors d'europe
où l'épidémie sera maîtrisée dès demain
en hexagone comme en outre mer
les crèches les écoles les collèges se
prépareront à accueillir à partir du 22
juin
tous les élèves de manière obligatoire
et selon les règles de présence normal
il faudra continuer d'éviter au maximum
lé rassemblement car nous savons qu'ils
sont les principales occasions de
propagation du virus
ils resteront donc très encadrée le
second tour des élections municipales
pourra se dérouler dans les communes
concernées le 28 juin
enfin pour nos aînés en maison de
retraite ou en établissement les visites
devront désormais être autorisé nous
allons donc pouvoir retrouver le plaisir
d'être ensemble de reprendre pleinement
le travail mais aussi de nous divertir
de nous cultiver
nous allons retrouver pour partie notre
art de vivre notre goût de la liberté en
somme nous allons retrouver pleinement
la france
cela ne signifie pas que le virus a
disparu et que nous pouvons baisser
totalement lagarde
il nous faudra pour longtemps encore
vivre avec lui
respecter les règles de distance
physique l'été 2020 ne sera pas un été
comme les autres et il nous faudra
veiller à l'évolution de l'épidémie
pour nous préparer au cas où elles
reviendraient avec plus de force
la lutte contre l'épidémie n'est donc
pas terminée mais je suis heureux avec
vous de cette première victoire contre
le virus et je veux ce soir en ce moment
lancé avec émotion à nos morts à leurs
familles dans le deuil a été rendue plus
cruelle encore en raison des contraintes
de cette période
alors aujourd'hui le moment entamé avec
le début du confinement n'avait rien
d'une évidence si nous pouvons rouvrir
le pays c'est parce qu'à chaque étape de
l'épidémie chacun a pris sa part le
premier ministre et le gouvernement ont
travaillé d'arrache-pied
le parlement s'est réuni l'état a tenu
les élus de terrain se sont engagés le
16 mars
nous avons fait le choix humaniste de
placer la santé au dessus de l'économie
en vous demandant de rester chez vous
vous avez alors fait preuve d'un sens
des responsabilités admirable et grâce à
l'engagement exceptionnel de nos
soignants et de toutes les équipes
l'ensemble des malades qui en avait
besoin ont pu être prises en charge à
l'hôpital ou dans la médecine de ville
grâce à tous ceux qui parmi vous ont
continué à travailler malgré l' angoisse
bien souvent pour assurer les services
essentiels à la nation nous avons pu
nous nourrir et continuer de vivre
lorsque le 13 avril dernier
je vous ai annoncé une sortie du
confinement à partir du 11 mai je sais
que beaucoup alors le déconseiller et
pas de consensus
les avis étaient très différents y
compris parmi les scientifiques mais
nous avons collectivement méthodiquement
préparé ce qu'on a appelé le
déconfinement là encore
tout le monde a travaillé d'arrache-pied
nous avons surmonté les craintes les
angoisses et vous est ressorti à nouveau
avait progressivement repris le travail
nous avons bien fait nos usines commerce
nos entreprises ont pu redémarrer la
nouvelle étape qui s'ouvre à partir de
demain va permettre d'accélérer la
reprise il le faut et là aussi je compte
sur vous car nous devons faire
pleinement repartir notre économie en
continuant de protéger les plus fragiles
nous n'avons pas à rougir
mes chers compatriotes de notre bilan
des dizaines de milliers de vies ont été
sauvées par nos choix
par nos actions nous avons su doubler en
quelques jours nos capacités de
réanimation organiser des transferts de
centaines de patients entre régions et
avec les pays voisins approvisionner nos
commerces réorienter notre production
industrielle inventer des nouvelles
solidarités
la période a montré que nous avions du
ressort de la ressource que face à un
virus qui nous a frappés plus tôt et
plus fort que beaucoup d'autres nous
étions capables d'être inventif réactif
solide
nous pouvons être fiers de ce qui a été
fait et de notre pays bien sûr cette
épreuve a aussi révélé des failles des
fragilités notre dépendance à d'autres
continents pour nous procurer certains
produits non lourdeur d'organisation nos
inégalités sociales et territoriales
je veux que nous tirions toutes les
leçons de ce que nous avons vécu est
avec vous comprendre ce que nous avons
mieux réussi au moins bien réussi que
nos voisins nos forces nous les
confronterons nos faiblesses nous les
corrigerons vite et fort
le moment que nous traversons et qui
vient après de nombreuses crises depuis
15 ans nous impose d'ouvrir une nouvelle
étape afin de retrouver pleinement la
maîtrise de nos vies de notre destin en
france et en europe
ce sera la priorité des deux années à
venir que je veux utile pour la nation
c'est aussi le cap de la décennie que
nous avons devant nous retrouver notre
indépendance
pour vivre heureux et vivre mieux avec
l'épidémie l'économie mondiale s'est
quasi arrêter notre première priorité
est donc d'abord de reconstruire une
économie forte écologique souveraine et
solidaire
depuis le premier jour de la crise notre
mobilisation est totale
quoi qu'il en coûte tel est l engagement
que j'avais pris devant vous dès le mois
de mars chômage partiel prêts aux
entreprises
accompagnement des commerçants des
indépendants soutien des plus précaires
tout a été mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement pour sauvegarder nos
emplois et pour aider chacun nous avons
décidé des plans massifs pour des
secteurs les plus durement touchés
l'industrie automobile l'aéronautique le
tourisme la culture la restauration
l'hôtellerie et nous poursuivrons au
total nous avons mobilisé près de 500
milliards d'euros pour notre économie
pour les travailleurs pour les
entrepreneurs mais aussi pour les plus
précaires
c'est inédit je veux ce soir que vous le
mesurier aussi pleinement dans combien
de pays tout cela at il été fait
c'est une chance et cela montre la force
de notre état de notre modèle social et
de notre économie
ces dépenses se justifier et se justifie
en raison des circonstances
exceptionnelles que nous venons de vire
mais elles viennent s'ajouter à notre
dette déjà existantes
nous ne financerons pas ses dépenses en
augmentant les impôts notre pays est
déjà l'un de ceux où la fiscalité est la
plus lourde
même si depuis trois ans nous avons
commencé à l'abaisser la seule réponse
est de bâtir un modèle économique
durable plus fort de travail et de
produire davantage pour ne pas dépendre
des autres et cela nous devons le faire
alors même que notre pays va connaître
des faillites et des plans sociaux
multiples en raison de l'arrêt de
l'économie mondiale c'est pourquoi
j'assumerai avec vous avec toutes les
forces de notre pays avec le tissu de
nos entreprises avec nos salariés comme
des indépendants
nos corps intermédiaires je m'engagerai
dans cette reconstruction économique
il nous faut d'abord tout faire pour
éviter au maximum les licenciements
c'est pour cela qu'avec les syndicats et
le patronat nous avons lancé une
négociation pour que dans toutes les
entreprises nous arrivions à préserver
le plus d'emplois possible malgré les
baisses d'activité il nous faut créer de
nouveaux emplois en investissant dans
notre indépendance technologique
numérique industrielle et agricole par
la recherche la consolidation des
filières l'attractivité et les
relocalisations lorsque cela se justifie
un vrai pacte productif
il nous faut aussi créer les emplois de
demain par la re construction écologique
qui réconcilie production et climat avec
un plan de modernisation du pays autour
de la rénovation thermique de nos
bâtiments des transports moins polluants
du soutien aux industries vertes
cela passera aussi par l'accélération de
notre stratégie maritime nous qui sommes
la deuxième puissance océanie
mondiale la convention citoyenne rendra
dans quelques jours son travail qui
contribuera à ce projet cette
reconstruction doit aussi être social et
solidaire une relance par la santé comme
nous avons commencé à le faire avec la
négociation du ségur qui non seulement
revalorisera les personnels soignants
mais permettra de transformer l'hôpital
comme la médecine de ville par des
investissements nouveaux et une
organisation plus efficace et préventive
une relance solidaire qui permettra de
mieux protéger nos aînés mieux protéger
aussi les plus pauvres d'entre nous une
relance sociale et solidaire enfin par
un investissement massif pour
l'instruction la formation et les
emplois de notre jeunesse nous le lui
devons nous lui avons tant demandée
durant cette période elle va encore
avoir un été une rentrée si difficile et
c'est elle qui porte la dette écologique
et budgétaire de notre pays
ce plan de reconstruction se fera avec
l'europe qui après des débuts timides
s'est hissé à la hauteur du moment
l'accord franco allemand autour d'un
endettement conjointe et d'un plan
d'investissement pour redresser
l'économie du continent est un tournant
historique en empruntant pour la
première fois ensemble avec la
chancelière d'allemagne
nous proposons aux autres états
européens de dire nous plutôt qu'une
addition de jeu c'est le résultat d'un
travail acharné
initiée par la france et que nous menons
depuis trois ans ce peut être là une
étape inédite de notre aventure
européenne et la consolidation d'une
europe indépendante qui se donne les
moyens d'affirmer son identité sa
culture sa singularité
face à la chine aux états unis et dans
le désordre mondial que nous connaissons
une europe plus forte plus solidaire
plus souveraine
c'est le combat
je mènerai en votre nom dès le conseil
européen de juillet et dans les deux
années à venir
cette reconstruction économique
écologique et solidaire sera la clé de
notre indépendance
elle sera préparée durant tout l'été
avec les forces vives de notre nation
pour être mise en oeuvre au plus vite
l'indépendance de la france pour vivre
mieux exige aussi notre unité autour de
la république tel est le deuxième axe de
cette nouvelle étape
je nous vois nous diviser pour tous et
parfois perdre le sens même de notre
histoire nous unir autour du patriotisme
républicain est une nécessité
nous sommes une nation où chacun quelles
que soient ses origines sa religion doit
trouver sa place est ce vrai partout et
pour tout le monde non notre combat doit
donc se poursuivre s'intensifier pour
permettre d'obtenir les diplômes et les
emplois qui correspondent aux mairies
des talents de chacun et lutter contre
le fait que le nom l'adresse la couleur
de peau réduisent encore trop souvent
dans notre pays
les chances que chacun doit avoir nous
serons intraitables face au racisme à
l'antisémitisme et aux discriminations
et de nouvelles décisions fortes pour
l'égalité des chances seront prises mais
ce combat noble et dévoyé
lorsqu'il se transforme en
communautarisme en réécriture haineuse
ou fausse du passé ce combat est
inacceptable lorsqu'il est récupéré par
les séparatistes
je vous le dis très clairement ce soir
mes chers compatriotes la république
n'effacera aucune trace ni aucun nom de
son histoire
elle n'oubliera aucune de ses oeuvres
elle ne déboulonnera pas de statut nous
devons plutôt lucidement regarder
ensemble toute notre histoire
toutes nos mémoires
notre rapport à l'afrique en particulier
pour bâtir un présent et un avenir
possible d'une rive l'autre de la
méditerranée avec une volonté de vérité
et en aucun cas de revisiter ou de nier
ce que nous sommes nous ne bâtirons pas
davantage notre avenir dans le désordre
sans ordre républicain
il n'y a ni sécurité ni liberté cet
ordre ce sont les policiers et les
gendarmes sur notre sol qui l'assurent
ils sont exposés à des risques
quotidiens en notre nom
c'est pourquoi ils méritent le soutien
de la puissance publique et la
reconnaissance de la nation
enfin il me reviendra avec vous de bâtir
de nouveaux équilibres dans les pouvoirs
et les responsabilités
c'est le troisième axe que je vois à
cette nouvelle étape
j'en ai la conviction profonde
l'organisation de l'état et de notre
action doit profondément changer tout ne
peut pas être décidé si souvent à paris
face à l'épidémie
les citoyens les entreprises les
syndicats les associations les
collectivités locales les agents de
l'état dans les territoires ont su faire
preuve d'ingéniosité d'efficacité de
solidarité faisons-leur davantage
confiance libérons la créativité et
l'énergie du terrain c'est pourquoi je
veux ouvrir pour notre pays une page
nouvelle donnant des libertés et des
responsabilités inédite à ceux qui
agissent au plus près de nos vies
liberté responsabilité pour nos hôpitaux
nos universités nos entrepreneurs nos
mères et beaucoup d'autres acteurs
essentiels
mes chers compatriotes ce projet
d'indépendance de reconstruction des
possibles que parce que depuis trois ans
nous avons mené un travail sans relâche
pour l'éducation l'économie
la lutte contre les inégalités dans
notre pays parce qu'aussi nous nous
sommes battus pour notre projet européen
et notre place dans l'ordre
international
je ne crois pas que surmonter les défis
qui sont devant nous consiste à revenir
en arrière
non mais les temps imposent de dessiner
un nouveau chemin
c'est ainsi que chacun d'entre nous doit
se réinventer comme je les dis que nous
devons collectivement faire différemment
et vous l'avez compris dans ce que j'ai
commencé ce soir esquissé je me
l'appliqué d'abord et avant tout à moi
même c'est dans cet esprit de concorde
que j'ai demandé aux présidents des deux
chambres parlementaires et du conseil
économique social et environnemental de
proposer quelques priorités susceptible
de rassembler le plus grand nombre
c'est aussi dans cet esprit que j'ai
engagé des consultations larges que je
poursuivrai durant les prochains jours
je m'adresserai à vous en juillet pour
préciser ce nouveau chemin lancé les
premières actions et cela ne s'arrêtera
pas
mes chers compatriotes nous avons devant
nous des défis historiques pour les
relever n'oublions jamais nos forces
notre histoire notre jeunesse notre sens
du travail et de l'engagement
notre volonté de justice notre
tu es de créer pour dire et changer le
monde
notre bienveillance agissons ensemble
avec toutes ses forces
cheville et au corps ayons ensemble
cette volonté de conquérir cette énergie
du jour qui vient
vive la république vive la france
et voilà donc pour l'allocution à des
manuels macron quatrième prise de parole
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
le chef de l'état qui a donc présenté
aux français son projet d'indépendance
et de reconstruction de la france après
cette crise une un projet sous trois
axes reconstruire une économie forte la
priorité a dit le chef de l'état
retrouver l'unité de la nation et puis
troisième acte une réorganisation de
l'état voilà pour les grandes lignes on
va entrer dans les détails avec vous
gilles casanova merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france vous êtes ancien
conseiller du ministère de l'intérieur
et consultant en stratégie et
communication
on avait déjà un peu les grandes lignes
de cette allocution qu'on avez-vous
pensé viens nous avons noté déjà huit
minutes de moins que la dernière fois
c'est un progrès la théâtralisation est
toujours là et le fond est toujours un
peu pauvres c'est à dire on a beaucoup
de grands mots beaucoup de grandes idées
comme souvent mais à un moment quand il
faut concrétiser
on se rend compte qu'on revient à du
classique c'est-à-dire tout ce que j'ai
fait depuis trois ans c'était bien je
vais continuer et on comprend pourquoi
69 % des français interrogés pensent
qu'il ne modifiera en rien sa stratégie
ou son rapport à la politique ou
français les français et la classe
politique attendait des actes concrets
ce qu'on sait en tout cas c'est qu'à
partir de demain il n'y aura plus de
zone orange en métropole tout va passer
au vert les restaurants vont
pouvoir rouvrir les écoles elles vont
pouvoir accueillir les élèves à partir
du 22 juin
voilà pour les choses concrètes
finalement ce ses grandes idées
présentées par le chef de l'état il a
pris soin de n'oublier personne
alors d'abord la grande idée on sait que
dans les études faites par les mêmes
instituts dans l'ensemble de l'occident
le gouvernement et les autorités
françaises sont celles qui ont le plus
mauvais résultat auprès de leur
population
quant à la capacité qu elles ont eu à
faire face à la crise du coronavirus
donc il sait cela évidemment
et donc il a d'abord adressé un énorme
satisfecit aux français qu'il a
poursuivie par un énorme satisfecit au
gouvernement qui s'est conclue par un
plus énorme encore satisfecit à lui-même
restant là dans son habituel stratégie
de communication comtois résumer à la
phrase qu'il a eue dans la fin de son
intervention et moi le tout premier
qu'il en fait tu aurais pu lire à peu
près à chaque paragraphe de ce qu'il a
dit ça c'est le premier aspect c'est à
dire finalement vous avez été tellement
bien que en y réfléchissant bien nous
aussi au gouvernement et moi-même à la
présidence
nous avons été bien en fuite il a dit
l'indépendance pas mais il n'a pas donné
la moindre piste cette indépendance
il a donné comme élément cette
indépendance la grande opération
proposée à l'union européenne avec
madame merkel qui consiste à emprunter
sur les marchés financiers
ce n'est pas la banque centrale
européenne qui va financer ce sont les
marchés financiers c'est à dire que on
va se mettre sur la tête une énorme
pression et dans un dispositif très
particulier puisque chaque fois que la
france touchera 30 milliards elle
garantir à 100 milliards
donc la pression sur la france dans ce
dispositif sera extrêmement forte dont
ils parlent d'indépendance il a même eu
le mot souveraineté mais on voit mal où
est la souveraineté
avec une telle pression il a parlé de
l'europe il a parlé aussi de
de se reconstruire de reconstruire le
monde de demain avec des grandes idées
je dois me l'appliqué à moi même at il
dit également c'est une humilité qu'on
lui connaît peu finalement il se remet
en question le chef de l'état vous
n'écoutez pas certaines chaînes
d'information qui le trouvent humble
tellement humble toujours plus humbles à
chacune de ses interventions
c'est un festival d'humilité ou du moins
il est présenté comme tel il est pas
plus humble que d'habitude
il est moi le tout premier c'est sa
stratégie
c'est comme ça qu'il l'a emporté en
étant au départ une personnalité peu
connue des français pensent et printemps
ça voudrait dire penser à moi
il a gagné la bataille présidentielle
autour de l'idée de penser printemps
quelques autres affaires que vous avez
noté ont un peu perturbé la campagne
mais le fond c'est que c'est lui le
projet puisque il a rassemblé des gens
qui ne pensent pas la même chose qui
viennent de droite qui viennent de
gauche qui pour ces élections
municipales ont refait des accords avec
la droite
on refait des accords avec la gauche
dans un désordre indescriptible
donc le programme c'est sa personne donc
son humilité est une humilité
théâtralisée car il n'a pas le choix il
n'y a pas d'autres orientations que de
suivre sa personne c'est aussi un
message au premier ministre dont il voit
difficilement comment il peut se
débarrasser
il a bien engagé beaucoup de
consultations mais pour l'instant ça
n'aboutit pas à trouver la réponse à
cette question il est dans la même
position nicolas sarkozy il y a dix ans
qui voulait se défaire de françois
fillon et qui finalement a été conduit à
le garder après six mois d'annonce que
on allait voir ce qu'on allait voir
alors on va l'écouter justement emmanuel
macron ce soir justement sur le bilan
qu'il tire de cette crise sanitaire
écouter premier bilan
bien sûr cette épreuve a aussi révélé
des failles des fragilités notre
dépendance à d'autres continents pour
nous procurer certains produits non
lourdeur d'organisation nos inégalités
sociales et territoriales
je veux que nous tirions toutes les
leçons de ce que nous avons vécu est
avec vous comprendre ce que nous avons
mieux réussi au moins bien réussi que
nos voisins nos forces nous les
confronterons nos faiblesses nous les
corrigerons vite et fort
voilà pour le bilan tiré c'est une
première victoire il s'est félicité de
cette victoire sur cette première étape
de de la crise sanitaire
pas de mot en tout cas sur est on prêt
pour une prochaine épidémie si tant est
qu'elles qu'elles arrivent à l'automne
chacun sait que nous n'y sommes pas pu
près que précédemment si ce n'est que
nous avons maintenant une surabondance
de masques et une surproduction puisque
les autorités ont demandé dans le
désordre à toute sorte d'acteur de
fabriquer des masques et que maintenant
nous avons un nombre de masques qui
dépasse largement ce que nous sommes
capables de consommer mais vous noterez
par exemple qu'il parle de l'aide
apportée aux à la filière automobile qui
a hérité de plusieurs milliards donc
elle est importante et il y dit avec des
mots toujours sur un style très théâtral
que sa saga aux entreprises et aux
travailleurs mais il n'a pas s'il y est
quand le groupe ps a annoncé qu'il
remplacerait 400 intérimaires français
par 400 polonais qui viennent sur la
base de la circulaire bolkenstein et ça
c'est tout de même une drôle de façon de
faire l'indépendance et la souveraineté
alors il dit aussi que pour redresser
l'économie de ce pays et et essayer de
combler ses 500 milliards d'euros qui
ont été débloqués par l'état
il n'y aura pas de hausse d'impôts pour
les français c'est une bonne nouvelle
j'imagine où on va là commenté avec vous
j'ai le casanova
il a beaucoup associé aussi la volonté
d'allier l'écologie à à l'économie
s'était attendu ça aussi oui c'est le
grand discours de l'epo logique qui
jette un discours obligé on lit dans les
gazettes qu'ils seront tous les
week-ends
à la lanterne à versailles ses
prédécesseurs s'y rendaient en voiture
avec des motards qui devait faire
beaucoup de pollution lui cire en
hélicoptère est-ce aussi écologistes que
ça alors on va écouter à présent
l'association human rights watch qui a
qui a alerté le chef de l'état en tous
cas sur les abus des forces de l'ordre
qui abuseraient en tout cas des
contrôles au faciès écouter ce qu'il
demandait et on va analyser ce qu'a
répondu à emmanuel macron ont froncé
emmanuel macron devrait indiquer la mise
en place de réformes concrètes pour
mettre fin au racisme au sein des forces
de l'ordre
ces réformes devraient inclure la fin
des contrôles d'identité abusifs et
discriminatoire au coeur des
préoccupations concernant le racisme
institutionnel et la discrimination dans
le pays
jean casanova vous l'avez entendu le
chef de l'état a abordé ce sujet plutôt
sensible à on sait qu'il a du mal à à en
parler en tout cas il a parlé de
retrouver l'unité du pays il a condamné
le racisme et dans le même temps il a
dit que l'ordre républicain ne pouvait
être assurée comme par les policiers
qu'il a salués il a bien fait écoutez il
a réaffirmé la république française face
à des gens qui proposent un dispositif
j'ai totalitaires dans lequel on va
réécrire l'histoire
déboulonner les statues condamner les
blancs parce que finalement on revient
dans un dispositif dans lesquels il y à
une race inférieure ce sont les blancs
voilà le dispositif
or on sait très bien dans les deux
dernières années que s'il y a eu des
violences policières c'est
essentiellement contre les filets jaunes
et pas pour des raisons raciales mais
pour des raisons politiques et que ce
n'est pas personnellement les policiers
qui ont décidé de violence contre les
gilets jaunes mais que c'était une
décision de l'exécutif
on se souvient de ses engagements aux
policiers à aller au contact directement
front tu es à ces manifestations ce
qu'ils ont fait d'ailleurs en ayant
eux-mêmes de nombreux blessés
donc on n'est pas du tout en phase d'une
police raciste qui ferait des contrôles
au faciès tout le temps on regarde la
réalité on se rend compte que la drogue
et la délinquance s'épanouissent dans
des quartiers de relégation dans lequel
on a relégué des gens qui sont arrivés
sur notre territoire plus tardivement et
qui sont d'une origine étrangère c'est
la réalité
alors évidemment ils sont souvent ou
parfois d'une couleur de peau légèrement
différente mais ce n'est pas le problème
de leur couleur de peau c'est le
problème d'avoir construit des zones de
relégation dans lequel s'épanouissent
les trafics et la délinquance c'est ça
le problème
alors si on dit maintenant quand vous
êtes noir ou quand vous êtes d'une
minorité visible vous avez le droit à
tous les trafics
évidemment ça n'est pas possible et il
est logique qu'un président de la
république française le réaffirme il ne
pouvait pas ne pas le faire et c'est
toujours la politique du dut en même
temps il ne contente un petit peu tout
le monde finalement dans son discours
moi le premier
comme il le dit je comprends les uns je
comprends les autres en même temps c'est
le fond de son programme
depuis trois ans il n'y a pas renoncé il
indique que c'est à partir de ce
programme qu'il va bâtir son avenir
du moins l'avenir du pays et son avenir
lui même puisque on voit qu'il vise la
présidentielle prochaine
et donc il est là contraint par ce qu'il
a lui même construit et qu'il en fait
d'un certain point de vue
il y aura une nouvelle méthode justement
est ce que le président a tiré des
leçons est ce qu'il y aura une nouvelle
méthode selon vous c'est ce que les
français attendent
il dit quelque chose qui change c'est
jusqu'ici ils voulaient détruire les
corps intermédiaires pour organiser une
verticalité absolue entre lui et les
français jupiter et ceux qui ne sont
rien là ils pensent que c'est finalement
très risquées et que le résultat n'a pas
jusqu'ici était la hauteur de ses
espoirs
donc il veut entraîner avec lui tous les
acteurs intermédiaires des collectivités
territoriales les maires les présidents
de conseils départementaux régionaux les
intercommunalités tout ce qui existe il
veut les entraîner derrière lui en leur
donnant des responsabilités des libertés
la difficulté c'est qu'il a pris soin
dans les trois années précédentes de
leur retirer tout leur financement
et c'est ce que réclame d'ailleurs les
communes et des territoires davantage de
liberté apparemment le message a été
entendu
la liberté oui mais il n'y a pas
l'argent qui va avec
c'est une difficulté à laquelle il va se
heurter d'autant que l'argent il y en a
beaucoup qui a été débloqué dans
l'urgence mais il n'est pas absolument
certain qu'il soit prêt à revenir sur
tous les dispositifs qui l'a mis en
place et qui ont dévitalisées les
capacités des collectivités
territoriales pour faire face à nos
responsabilités on vous restez avec nous
à gilles casanova on va prendre la
direction de l'elysée à présent pour
faire un point justement sur ce qu'a dit
le chef de l'état dans son discours de
19 minutes ce soir on va retrouver
nadège abderrazak devant le palais de
l'elysée
nadège bonsoir vous avez suivi
évidemment ce discours pour rt france
que faut-il en retenir précisément
écoutez magali emmanuel macron a
commencé son discours par de bonnes
nouvelles pour les français le passage
en zone verte de tout l'hexagone
exceptés les territoires de guyane de
mayotte avec une reprise plus forte du
travail et la réouverture des bars et
restaurants en ile-de-france est les
frontières françaises rouvre à pauvres à
partir de demain les déplacements en
dehors de l'union européenne seront
possibles à partir du 1er juillet dans
les pays qui auront réussi à maîtriser
l'épidémie l école sera obligatoire pour
tous à partir du 22 juin le président de
la république a appelé à éviter au
maximum lé rassemblement qui sont de
potentiels foyers de contamination du
virus selon lui il a aussi confirmé
cette date du 28 juin pour le second
tour des élections municipales il ne
faut pas baisser la garde il faut
continuer à vivre avec le virus
apprendre à vivre avec le virus et
respecter les gestes barrière il a
insisté le chef de l'état sur ce point
et malgré un bilan humain qui atteint
près de 30000 morts le chef de l'état
s'est dit satisfait de ce bilan la
france n'a pas à rougir de ce bilan
puisque des dizaines de milliers
d'autres vies ont été sauvées grâce à la
politique du gouvernement à ce sujet je
vous propose de l'écouter
nous n'avons pas à rougir mes chers
compatriotes de notre bilan des dizaines
de milliers de vies ont été sauvées par
nos choix
par nos actions nous avons su doubler en
quelques jours nos capacités de
réanimation organiser des transferts de
centaines de patients entre régions et
avec les pays voisins approvisionner le
commerce réorienter notre production
industrielle inventer des nouvelles
solidarités
la période a montré que nous avions du
ressort de la ressource que face à un
virus qui nous a frappés plus tôt et
plus fort que beaucoup d'autres nous
étions capables d'être inventif réactif
solide
emmanuel macron a aussi appelé à une
réorganisation de l'état syndicats
associations et citoyen seront
sollicités on l'écoutait suger j'en ai
la conviction profonde
l'organisation de l'état et de notre
action doit profondément changer tout ne
peut pas être décidé si souvent à paris
face à l'épidémie
les citoyens les entreprises les
syndicats les associations les
collectivités locales les agents de
l'état dans les territoires ont su faire
preuve d'ingéniosité d'efficacité de
solidarité faisons-leur davantage
confiance libérons la créativité et
l'énergie du terrain c'est pourquoi je
veux ouvrir pour notre pays une page
nouvelle donnant des libertés et des
responsabilités inédite à ceux qui
agissent au plus près de nos vies
liberté responsabilité pour nos hôpitaux
nos universités nos entrepreneurs nos
mères et beaucoup d'autres acteurs
essentiels
emmanuel macron a appelé les français à
être plus solidaires il a condamné le
racisme l'antisémitisme et toutes formes
de discrimination et dans le même temps
il a tenu à rendre hommage au policier
gendarme garant de l'ordre républicain
emmanuel macron qui devrait à nouveau
s'exprimer pour une cinquième allocution
depuis le début de la crise ce sera
courant juillet merci beaucoup nadège
pour ce point complet sur le discours à
des manuels macron ce soir gilles
casanova une dernière question pour vous
emmanuel macron doit reprendre la parole
nadège ad razak le disait en juillet
prochain ce sera pour une 10e une
dissolution un remaniement
écoutez d'abord où on doit noter que ce
qu'il a fait était sur la forme très
léchée très beau c'est est enregistrée
et déjà il y a un vrai souci du du
design de l'image
on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas encore de
programme
il n'y a pas encore de décision il n'y a
pas encore de stratégie
il annonce donc qu'il
donnera ses conclusions en juillet il ne
donne pas de date précise
il indique qu'il a consultés qu'il va
consulter
c'est un petit peu la prophétie auto
réalisatrice
c'est à dire qu'il espère qu à force
d'annoncer qu'il consulte partout et
tout le monde tout le monde à venir vers
lui en essayant de lui proposer ses
services
car pour l'instant et il ne trouve pas
beaucoup de personnalités qu'ils soient
prêts à monter sur son char où chaque
son bras de suivre le regard que l'on
porte
merci beaucoup j'ai une casanova d'avoir
était en direct sur astel france pour
analyser cette allocution du président
de la république
on va retrouver à présent jérôme marty
médecin et président du syndicat unef ml
l'union française pour une médecine
libre un bon soir jérôme marty merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors on attendait beaucoup le président
évidemment sur le personnel soignant et
le travail extraordinaire réalisé
pendant cette crise
emmanuel macron à remercier évidemment à
cette mobilisation extraordinaire des
services de santé mais où en est-on de
ce ségur de la santé qui a été initiée
le 25 mai dernier avec olivier verrons
qu'en est il aujourd'hui
pour l'instant on n'a pas grand chose
puisque on les bat vraiment rentrer dans
le dur il ya eu des réunions qui ont été
annulés annulé au dernier moment
on commence à peine les discussions
vraisemblablement ou est-ce que ça va
mener très difficile à dire on a bien
entendu le président de la république
qui a parlé de donner plus de liberté
aux soignants mais dans quelles
conditions
dans quel cadre pour cela reste
relativement vague tant qu'on ne sera
pas sorti en fait de ce lien
administratif extrêmement puissante que
l'on peut avoir avec les agences de
santé et avec l'état qui est quand même
la main sur la santé tente en médecine
de ville la médecine hospitalière
on n'aura pas un nouveau schéma est donc
on n'aura pas une nouvelle organisation
de la société
est-ce que néanmoins les indications que
le chef de l'état a donné ce soir vous
satisfont investissements également
promis par le chef de l'état de nouveaux
investissements
la goutte et on ne peut que
on a envie de le croire a envie de
suivre ce qu'il dit quand il parle tels
des pandas ce mot qui nous est cher
quand il quand il parle de refonder en
quelque sorte
l'avenir de la phrase d'aller dans les
énergies nouvelles peut aller vers une
écologie solidaire et ça ça fait partie
également de la santé donc de notre
mission on a envie de croire le seul
problème c'est que par exemple lorsqu'il
parle de celle des 500 milliards qui ont
été dépensés pour soutenir les
entreprises pour soutenir l'économie
française la vraie question et se
demander si il lui fallut 500 milliards
si nous avions voulu les masques si nous
avions eu les tests si nous avions eu il
aidé des milliers de lits de réanimation
qui nous ont manqué si la france en bref
avec étaient mieux préparés certainement
cette crise pourrait coûter moins cher
donc tout ça ça montre qu' il faut
sortir de cette politique qui jusqu'à
présent en régie la santé parce que
cette politique nous a emmenés dans le
mur
alors oui on a envie de quoi mais lui il
va falloir qu'ils nous donnent des gages
qu'il nous montre des actes qui vont
nous laisser voir en fait on nous
laissait entendre que véritablement on
refourgue vraiment ce qui a encadré
jusqu'à présent n'a cité que l'on donne
une part du pouvoir ce mot est peut-être
dur mais c'est celui ci qu'il faut une
part du pouvoir et d'organisation aux
soignants sur la santé est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec le chef de l'état qui
parle d'une victoire finalement après
cette première étape de déconfinement il
aurait dû davantage faire un mea culpa
justement sur ces manquements dont vous
parlez au début de la crise non je crois
que l'on peut pas parler de victoire
d'abord on était aux lecteurs on aurait
quand même du mal à parler des victoires
alors qu'on n'a plus de 30000 morts
qu'on n'a pas comptabilisé en cours les
décès qui se sont refaits à domicile
alors qu'ont à 46 médecins libéraux qui
sont décédés et médecins hospitaliers
qu'on a encore des soignants qui sont en
réanimation que on a eu tous et tous et
poussez donc c'est que ces milliers de
morts je crois qu'on doit parler de
victoire on peut parler
par contre de l'engagement fort d'une
responsabilité forte devant le soin qui
a été celle des soignants d'une
responsabilité qui a été celle de tous
les français de faire que
puisse sortir de ce confinement qui a
été de respecter les consignes on a vu
que l on était relativement à majorité
respecter et puis une sortie du bois
finement qui a débuté donc le 11 mai qui
doit s'accélérer avec eux l'ensemble des
français qui doit jouer chacun doit
jouer son rôle pour relancer l'économie
française c'est plus de cela que dont il
faut parler c'est plus de cette
responsabilité française cet engagement
des français que d'une victoire je crois
connaître
on a été au contraire à ce combat on a
été contraint à faire face et on se
serait bien passé mais encore une fois
ce n'était pas une guerre c'était un
combat pour la vie et ce combat pour la
vie qui a été menée par les français
pendant cette crise emmanuel macron à
remercier d'ailleurs ceux qui ont
continué à travailler les soignants bien
évidemment il a parlé aussi des aînés il
a parlé des jeunes
il a annoncé donc la réouverture là le
passage en zone verte maintenant pour
toute la métropole à partir de demain on
va écouter le chef de l'état qui met en
garde néanmoins le virus est toujours là
at il dit nous allons retrouver
pleinement la france cela ne signifie
pas que le virus a disparu et que nous
pouvons baisser totalement lagarde
il nous faudra pour longtemps encore
vivre avec lui respecter les règles de
distance physique l'été 2020 ne sera pas
un été comme les autres et il nous
faudra veiller à l'évolution de
l'épidémie pour nous préparer au cas où
elles reviendraient avec plus de force
la lutte contre l'épidémie n'est donc
pas terminée mais je suis heureux avec
vous de cette première victoire contre
le virus jérôme marty est ce que les
français peuvent reprendre une vie quasi
normale on va dire oui ils peuvent
reprendre une vie normale mais comme le
dit manuel macro et il a réseau en
gardant à l'esprit qu'il va falloir
continuer à respecter un certain nombre
de gestes barrières et puis surtout il
faut connaître ce virus il faut
apprendre à l'étudier il faut se
préparer et il faut savoir réagir si
tenté que malheureusement l'épidémie
reprenait après les vacances horizon
encore horizons nous
mo décembre ne sais pas personne
aujourd'hui est capable de le dire ce
qu'on sait c'est que le terrain de jeu
de ce virus c'est la terre entière
on voit bien qu'il ya des pays où celui
qui se développe fortement des pays où
ils réémerge nous nous sommes dans une
période qui est très calme où le virus
est repassé en quelques sortes soit
boisseau même s'il ya un certain nombre
de clusters que l'on ne découvre pas ce
contexte beaucoup plus le virus continue
à circuler à bas bruit
donc il faut il fait partie de nourrir
falloir apprendre à vivre avec lui et
après la vidange est glissée respecter
pour jour un certain nombre de gestes
barrière alors justement on attendait
aussi le chef de l'état pour savoir si
l'arsenal est prêt en cas de rebond de
cette épidémie charles arsenal puisque
le chef de l'état a parlé d'une guerre
est ce que selon vous on est prêt alors
il ya des masques il ya des tests mais
est ce qu'on est prêt à l'hôpital jérôme
marty à accueillir de nouveaux malades
si le virus revenait à l'automne oui on
est on est on est beaucoup plus prêts
que nous l'avons été faut pas oublier
quand même que malheureusement un des
principaux clijsters et l'hôpital
puisque l'hôpital était au départ mal
préparé et beaucoup de soignants ont été
contaminés et donc les fous dans les
foyers de contamination il ya l'hôpital
ce n'est certainement plus le cas
aujourd'hui parce que les matériels sont
en fait arrivé et puis les personnels
soignants sont aguerris à la lutte
contre le bruit de 19
c'est la même chose dans les
établissements médico sociaux dans les
ehpad dans les cliniques privées dans
les sprints suite
les personnels ont appris à faire face
la médecine libérale également donc nous
sommes prêts nous sommes prêts s'il
devait y avoir un nouvel assaut de ces
virus
nous saurons réagir et les français
également ont appris à le connaître
d'après lui parler lui c'est pour ça que
quelque sorte nous pourrons réagir
beaucoup plus vite et sans doute sans
doute pas que cet apprentissage
arriverons nous empêcher l'importance
d'une deuxième pole quand vous dites que
vous êtes prêt ça veut dire qu'il y
aurait davantage de lille il ya des
respirateurs il ya des des produits
anesthésiants tout ce qui faisait défaut
en tout cas absolument ça vous savez
bien que norme pour les hommes on l'est
toujours en pénurie de matériel
notamment dans l'esthétique et de les
deux dépôts de produits qui servent aux
gestes à la réanimation qui sont encore
à flux tendu qui ont été mis en
hier par l'état qui arrive avec
relativement parcimonie les lits de
réanimation n'y en a pas plus vous le
savez on est toujours sur cinq mille
civils lit il faudra sans doute en créer
davantage mais c'est dans cet intervalle
de temps les quelques mois qui viennent
que doit se faire cette politique de
relance véritable visage guide de
l'hôpital public et de relance véritable
vis-à-vis de la médecine de ville
il va falloir apprendre à compter
autrement qu'avec le souci économique eu
le souci de ne pas investir dans la
santé le falher au contraire investir
massivement en quelque sorte
l'austérité en santé doit prendre fin on
doit penser d'abord aux mains qui soigne
qui saute
celle qui demain pour vous éviter une
nouvelle propagation de cette épidémie
et ses personnels soignants avec la mais
aussi une revalorisation des salaires
qui n'ont pas pour l'instant obtenu ils
ont ils ont des promesses en ce sens en
tout cas c'est une annonce qu aurait dû
faire également le chef de l'état je
parle aussi des stagiaires qui ont
beaucoup contribué à aider dans les
hôpitaux et qui ont été sous payés mais
c'est tout le tout le monde de soignants
vous savez le moins de soignants il n'ya
pas d'ailleurs que les soignants il ya
toutes les professions qui permettent de
faire tourner les hôpitaux
il s'agit des ae sage des brancardiers
dans les soignants les exfoliante
jusqu'aux médecins les chirurgiens les
anesthésistes les infirmières c'est tout
le personnel soignant qui doit être
aujourd'hui mieux considérées ce mode
considération est extrêmement important
parce que bien sûr il ya les tarifs bien
sûr il à la rémunération mais il ya
aussi la considération et la
considération ça veut dire qu'il faut
accepter de déléguer un certain nombre
de pouvoirs que cette seule poids
administratif doit laisser un certain
nombre de pouvoirs aux soignants de
façon à ce que ce soit le soin qui
orientaient la destinée des hôpitaux le
soin qui oriente la destinée de la
médecine de ville et non pas encore une
fois des contraintes budgétaires
merci beaucoup un jérôme marty vous
auriez aimé pour finir entendre en
entendre davantage de la part du
président d'un côté choix il a dit qu'il
allait une refaire un point au mois de
juillet 10 le mois de juillet c'est donc
dans un mois on va voir un peu moi
comment les choses ont évolué et on aura
d'ailleurs les premiers rendus du ségur
de la santé oms aura davantage bonne
année on espère que les leçons devant
être tirées de cette crise majeure
aujourd'hui nous rentrons dans une crise
économique qui est gravissime pour le
pays
chacun va devoir faire face je crois que
là encore une fois on avait parlé d'
équipe de france pour lutter contre le
combi 19 et falloir parler l'équipe de
france pour lutter comme ça et on en
reparlera évidemment en juillet lorsque
le président vous prendra la parole on
refera un nouveau bilan merci beaucoup
géré marty d'avoir analysé cette
allocution présidentielle pour rt france
on va les écouter à la principale
information donnée ce soir par par le
chef de l'état la zone orange qui
n'existe plus en métropole
l'ile-de-france qui repassent au vert à
partir de demain c'était en tout cas la
grande attente des français retrouvés à
davantage de liberté de mouvement et
surtout pour les restaurateurs qui vont
pouvoir accueillir du public à
l'intérieur l'un des restaurants écouter
le chef de l'état dès demain tout le
territoire à l'exception de mayotte et
de la guyane où le virus circule encore
activement tout le territoire donc
passera dans ce qu'il est désormais
convenu d'appeler la zone verte ce qui
permettra notamment une reprise plus
forte du travail et la réouverture des
cafés et restaurants en ile de france
dès demain il sera à nouveau possible de
se déplacer entre les pays européens et
à partir du 1er juillet nous pourrons
nous rendre dans les états hors d'europe
où l'épidémie sera maîtrisée dès demain
en hexagone comme en outre mer
les crèches les écoles les collèges se
prépareront à accueillir à partir du 22
juin
tous les élèves de manière obligatoire
et selon les règles de présence normal
et voilà donc pour les principales
annonces du chef de l'état ce soir on
fera un point sur cette information
évidemment dans notre prochain journal
dans 10 minutes exactement rester avec
nous
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça fout les jetons on est dans une
espèce de déni collectif on ne veut pas
croire ce qu'on sait et scientifique
parle quand même de la sixième
extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction des zones de la vie
sur terre et à d'autres experts qui
contestent leur six personnes non non
c'est pas vrai il ya des climats tout
c'est maintenant et non ce n'est pas il
y en a pas il ya des gens qui ne sont
pas des chercheurs qui parlent que la
presse met en avant parce que il faut
que du débat mais il ya plus de débat
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun débat ce
changement climatique et on va vers un
vrai par une catastrophe ou va vers une
vraie catastrophe et on est incapable
d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas des pessimistes de
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et les demies il
n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
ici on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne pour
profit de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président très pratique et le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais si j'ai bien compris ils
sont morts pour rien puisque au nom
d'une idéologie on nie leur existence en
oubliant une partie de la game
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire les bêtes des idées
courageuse des mots qui comptent
elle conçoit vient des lignes
aujourd'hui une gauche plus extrêmes
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
l'afrique et compte 1 1 % de cas dans le
monde sait très peu comment vous
l'expliquez nous devons considérer que
les chiffres sont sous-estimés mais nous
ne sommes pas encore au niveau où se
trouve par exemple l'hérault pour les
états unis quelle stratégie vous avez
déployés dans le sud kivu pour limiter
la propagation du virus on a proposé à
ce qu'est le confinement puisse être
sélectif est concerné seulement des
personnes âgées à haut risque de
complication pour sensibiliser la
population ça l'est beaucoup plus
facilement puisque on venait de sortir
d'une épidémie d'ebola qui exige
également la distanciation social lavage
des mains
si on aura affaire à deux épidémies
aussi dangereuse qui est des mollahs et
coronavirus ça pourrait être très très
difficile où on vit tous les jours sans
faire attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous s'il
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je suis
finissent par renoncer au soir vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck fall que
ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
quoi construire les fiches avec les
acteurs associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
aussi on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si seul un père dit d'un
ternie
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france les cours et les violences
existait avant leur confinement
et pendant ce compliment c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre l'état sur les
taux des féminicides a plus que je dis
pas doublé mais bien monté forcément on
n'a pas encore tous les chiffres
officiels c'est très difficile gros
n'est jamais n'est jamais loin
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux repas à 3
[Musique]
elle
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
la métropole en zone verte dès demain
les restaurants pourront ouvrir
normalement les élèves devront tous
revenir en cours dès le 22 juin prochain
ce sont les principales annonces du chef
de l'état ce soir la france qui doit se
remettre également au travail
emmanuel macron qui s'est adressé aux
français pour la quatrième fois ce soir
depuis le début de la crise
il a également réagi pour la première
fois sur les récentes mobilisations
contre le racisme en france
[Musique]
le chef de l'état qui a marqué son
soutien aux forces de l'ordre tout en
condamnant le racisme des policiers
français toujours en colère et hier soir
devant l'arc de triomphe à paris ils ont
chanté la marseillaise et jeté à terre
leurs menottes
une manifestation qui s'est déroulée à
l'issue d'une grande mobilisation contre
le racisme 15000 personnes rassemblées
place de la république avec des tensions
face aux forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
trois semaines après le décès de georges
floyd aux états unis un afro-américain
décède sous les balles de la police à
atlanta il a été mortellement blessé
alors qu'il tentait d'échapper à un
contrôle des autorités
l'homme en état d'ébriété se serait
emparé du taser de l'un des policiers
avant de prendre la fuite
l'agent responsable du pire a été
renvoyé la cheffe de la police d'atlanta
a démissionné
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir l'allocution du
président de la république c'était la
quatrième fois qu'il s'adressait aux
français depuis le début de la crise
avait parmi les principales annonces du
chef de l'état est la métropole qui
repassent au vert entièrement à dès
demain elle et restaurants pourront donc
rouvrir normalement les élèves ne
patienteront jusqu'au 22 juin pour
revenir à l'école et les français
doivent se remettre au travail
on va faire on va rejoindre tout de
suite à l'elysée notre reporter nadège
abderrazak on va écouter le chef de
l'état d'abord dès demain tout le
territoire à l'exception de mayotte et
de la guyane où le virus circule encore
activement tout le territoire donc
passera dans ce qu'il est désormais
convenu d'appeler la zone verte ce qui
permettra notamment une reprise plus
forte du travail et la réouverture des
cafés et restaurants en ile de france
dès demain il sera à nouveau possible de
se déplacer entre les pays européens et
à partir du 1er juillet nous pourrons
nous rendre dans les états hors d'europe
où l'épidémie sera maîtrisée dès demain
en hexagone comme en outre mer
les crèches les écoles les collèges se
prépareront à accueillir à partir du 22
juin
tous les élèves de manière obligatoire
et selon les règles de présence normal
et voilà donc parmi les principales
annonces du chef de l'état concernant à
la vie en france et on va retrouver à
l'elysée notre reporter nadège
abderrazak bonsoir nadège que faut-il
retenir par ailleurs de cette allocution
du chef de l'état ce soir 4e allocution
du chef de l'état depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire un discours de 19
minutes au cours duquel le président de
la république a insisté il ne faut pas
baisser la garde il faut continuer à
vivre avec le virus le chef de l'état
insisté il faut continuer à respecter
les gestes barrière
malgré un bilan humain de 30 mille
victimes le chef de l'état estime que la
france n'a pas à rougir de ce bilan il
affirme le gouvernement à la gestion
gouvernementale de cette crise a permis
de sauver des dizaines d'autres vies et
coûté des dizaines de milliers d'autres
nous n'avons pas à rougir
mes chers compatriotes de notre bilan
des dizaines de milliers de vies ont été
sauvées par nos choix
par nos actions nous avons su doubler en
quelques jours nos capacités de
réanimation organiser des transferts de
centaines de patients entre régions et
avec les pays voisins approvisionner nos
commerces réorienter notre production
industrielle inventer des nouvelles
solidarités
la période a montré que nous avions du
ressort de la ressource que face à un
virus qui nous a frappés plus tôt et
plus fort que beaucoup d'autres nous
étions capables d'être inventif réactif
solide emmanuel macron appelé les
français à être plus unis plus solidaire
dans ce contexte international de
manifestation contre le racisme contre
les violences policières emmanuel macron
a pris la parole pour la première fois
pour dénoncer le racisme et toute forme
de discrimination il a dans le même
temps est bien rendu hommage aux
gendarmes et policiers garant selon lui
je cite de l'ordre républicain en
l'écoutent
nous sommes une nation où chacun quelles
que soient ses origines sa religion doit
trouver sa place
est ce vrai partout et pour tout le
monde non notre combat doit donc se
poursuivre s'intensifier pour permettre
d'obtenir les diplômes et les emplois
qui correspondent au mérite des talents
de chacun et lutter contre le fait que
le nom l'adresse la couleur de peau
réduisent encore trop souvent dans notre
pays
les chances que chacun doit avoir nous
serons intraitables face au racisme à
l'antisémitisme et aux discriminations
et de nouvelles décisions fortes pour
l'égalité des chances seront prises mais
ce combat
non
et dévoyé lorsqu'il se transforme en
communautarisme en réécriture haineuse
ou fausse du passé ce combat est
inacceptable lorsqu'il est récupéré par
les séparatistes
je vous le dis très clairement ce soir
mes chers compatriotes la république
n'effacera aucune trace ni aucun nom de
son histoire
elle n'oubliera aucune de ses oeuvres
elle ne déboulonnera pas de statut nous
devons plutôt lucidement regarder
ensemble toute notre histoire
toutes nos mémoires notre rapport à
l'afrique en particulier pour bâtir un
présent et un avenir possible d'une rive
à l'autre de la méditerranée avec une
volonté de vérité et en aucun cas de
revisiter ou de nier ce que nous sommes
emmanuel macron qui devrait à nouveau
s'exprimer ce sera courant juillet au
sujet de la gestion de cette crise donc
sanitaires liés aux coville 19 merci
beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions et on continue d'en parler
avec nicolas vidal directeur de la
publication directeur de publication de
putsch médias bonsoir nicolas vidal
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
nous n'avons pas à rougir de notre bilan
a dit le chef de l'état vous êtes
d'accord alors emmanuel macron il a fait
un quatrième à qu'il a délaissé la
moraline emmanuel macron pour
l'autosatisfaction des gens qui ne doute
absolument de rien ça c'est pour en
préambule est que laure moi ce soir j'ai
frétiller très sincèrement sur mon
canapé parce que j'ai entendu plusieurs
fois le mot indépendance france
indépendante et ça j'ai trouvé dès le
début qu'on avait quelque chose de
novateur d'un discours d' emmanuel
macron bien violent tendu le pessimisme
m'a rattrapé immédiatement donc pour
revenir sur ce point d'indépendance et
en entendu économie souveraine
écologique louer les dans celui de
l'état les relocalisations les
investissements dans l'économie
tout ça finalement on a senti qu'il y
avait une volonté de remettre là
son centre du jeu mais vous savez et
magali c'est toujours le même temps avec
manuel macron donc après on nous a
resservi le réchauffé du micron de
l'union européenne avec vous savez
toujours ses grandes panégyrique de
l'union européenne forte europe
solidaire souveraine sociale tout ce
qu'on entend en permanence donc emmanuel
macron il revient finalement sur cette
idée par du en même temps parce que je
pense que c'est ça qui est central
aujourd'hui dans ce discours pour moi
selon mon avis c'est cette idée toujours
de l'ambivalence permanence et on verra
sur le plan de la relance pour en dire
quelques mots
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
énorme là dessus ça a été tout a été
très conceptuel par rapport à emmanuel
mâcon pencran mais on est vraiment sous
une nouvelle danse de la pluie vous
savez une espèce de grande sagesse aride
de ceux de cette crise économique heures
absolument redoutable qu'on est en train
de voir venir et je crois qu emmanuel
macron voilà sur ce discours là c'était
vraiment encore le en même temps aux
permanences alors il n'y a pas eu
d'annoncé concrète
effectivement à part le passage de la
métropole en tout cas en zone verte dès
demain la vie doit doit reprendre les
français doivent retrouver leur liberté
a dit le chef de l'état ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour vous ben oui
forcément je vais vous dire que
personnellement et nous toutes et nous
tous a envie de reprendre une vie
normale mais il faut toujours accéder ce
qui va se passer dans dans quelques
jours il ya déjà la manif des soignants
il ya toute une vous révolte sociale et
populaire qui a encore la de plus en
plus lourdes en france est une nouvelle
fois je le dis cette cette politique en
permanence de se tourner vers l'europe
en nous par d'accords historiques avec
l'allemagne je suis pas aussi optimiste
qui manuel macro on nous refait le coup
du couple franco-allemand qui est pour
moi un couple virtuel un parce que
sadomasochistes à un moment donné on
peut pas toujours se tourner par union
européenne et je crois que la
souveraineté économique à souveraineté
sanitaires on l'a vu avec la crise des
masques on l'a vu avec les tests on l'a
vu avec le nom fermeture des frontières
il n'ya que finalement nos souverainetés
qui aurait pu
- paraît ce virus rappelez-vous magali
quand emmanuel macron et les chapiteaux
européenne lui disais il ya que l'europe
finalement qui peut le protéger de la
chine de l'inde du brésil états unis
on s'est rendu compte une nouvelle fois
que l'union européenne nous a protégés
d'absolument de personnes et que tout le
monde fera mais ses frontières s'est
claquemuré sur son territoire sa
souveraineté pour essayer de faire face
comme on a pu donc concrètement une
nouvelle fois on ouvre aussi qu'une
logis rappelez vous le 16 mars on nous a
fait en mars emmanuel macron à ce
premier acte nous avait parlé qu'il
fallait se réinventer il fallait voir la
modélisation sous notre jour aujourd'hui
on nous ressert absolument la même
tambouille néolibérale et et la réforme
des retraites n'est pas à première vue
abandonné par emmanuel macron donc vous
voyez moi j'ai pas l'impression que ça a
changé si ce n'est après peut-être qu'on
va en parler de cette déclaration sur la
france qui se dérouleront à pâques ne
niera pas son histoire ça sincèrement on
va en parler effectivement et je
voudrais qu'on écoute d'abord le chef de
l'état sur qui a admis quelques
faiblesses néanmoins bien sûr cette
épreuve a aussi révélé des failles des
fragilités notre dépendance à d'autres
continents pour nous procurer certains
produits non lourdeur d'organisation nos
inégalités sociales et territoriales
je veux que nous tirions toutes les
leçons de ce que nous avons vécu est
avec vous comprendre ce que nous avons
mieux réussi au moins bien réussi que
nos voisins nos forces nous les
confronterons nos faiblesses nous les
corrigerons vite et fort où il va
falloir tirer toutes les leçons est ce
que pour vous il ya déjà une esquisse de
ces leçons à tirer par le chef de l'état
dans son discours ce soir mais on en est
toujours à déclaration d'intention avec
emmanuel macron parce qu'on n'arrive pas
à faire la synthèse effectivement avec
ça mais je ne vous crois pas fait le son
il a tiré mais gens pareils en préambule
il ya une espèce de satisfaction ne peut
pas nier les énormes et roman les nerds
énorme erreur que l'état français sur
les masques notamment et les tests et
même sur les lits d'hôpitaux mots sont
toujours rappeler que c'est la france
périphérique a sorti le pays en partie
de ce bourbier on rappellera les
soignants qui sont allés en première
ligne
donc finalement c'est la résidence alors
je reprends mon encontre
plutôt le terme d' emmanuel macron la
résilience de la région celle est venue
de quoi elle est venue de l'essence même
de la france de la france périphérique
l'état était totalement dépassé sur
cette crise alors on nous dit oui tous
les pays ont été frappées
oui mais à un moment donné on n'avait
pas aussi des armes pour lutter
efficacement contre ce virus ou du moins
l'endiguer plus tôt et plus fort et plus
vite dans mois une nouvelle fois c'est
toujours de la grande déclaration
d'intention avec cette espèce de
panégyrique du en même temps et ça ça
n'a jamais sorti un pays de l'afrique
onomique dans lequel la bise économies
dans lequel nous sommes en train de le
voir propulser précipitée alors le chef
de l'état qui a condamné également le
racisme tout en saluant le rôle des
forces de l'ordre en france rôle
essentiel selon le chef de l'état bien
sûr il a dit aussi que on n'allait pas à
déboulonner des statuts et qu'il fallait
garder et ne pas rougir non plus deux
des identités des oreilles des autres
qu'en pensez vous alors venue de macron
oui c'est du transport n'est pas
débouler les statuts pas nier notre
histoire pareille histoire où la
remontée certes très bien jusqu'à là on
peut lui accorder un peu de légitimité
mais je vous rappelle qu emmanuel macron
en pré campagne à lyon dans un discours
il avec emi qui n'existait pas de
culture française qui avait une culture
française pluriel donc emmanuel macron
et l'appareil toujours le même sentiment
sur ce qu'est la culture française
l'identité française
donc ça c'est extrêmement important et
puis une nouvelle fois je pense que
manuel macron pour moi c'est pas un
président république c'est un
gestionnaire
on l'a vu de l'union européenne pour
faire très vite un pur part c'était là
dessus et finalement le problème a mis
tellement des fractures très importante
au grand jour qu'il ne peut pas faire
autrement aujourd'hui que de réagir sur
ce point mais je crois que là-dessus
emmanuel macron il est un peu faible sur
les pattes arrière alors il a fait il a
été père antoine aujourd'hui sur
l'histoire française est une nouvelle
fois c'est assez novateur dans son
discours mais je prends une même pas que
c'est vraiment la déclaration
d'intention et on verra si c'est suivi
d'effet rappelez-vous le discours sur la
laïcité notamment sur un terme beaucoup
plus large
on l'attend toujours ce grand discours
donc moi pour l'instant je n'accorde
aucun crédit
eni deux points de confiance tous hakim
annuel marquant c'est une histoire de
points en gros on points en juillet et
vous savez aujourd'hui les l'histoire
des points en france et la forme des
retraites est très à la mode chez
emmanuel macron merci beaucoup nicolas
vidal pour votre
alise merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france ce soir
l'hôpital et les soignants le chef de
l'état a eu des mots aussi pour saluer
le travail effectué pendant cette crise
par ces personnels qui sont toujours
dans la tente d'une réorganisation de
l'hôpital il y a le fameux plan ségur
qui a été initiée le 25 mai et qui se
fait toujours attendre en termes d'
actes concrets écouter ce qu'on dit le
docteur jérôme marty il est médecin et
président du syndicat de l'union
française pour une médecine libre on a
envie de le croire le seul problème
c'est que par exemple lorsqu'il parle de
ces décès 100 milliards ont été dépensés
pour soutenir les entreprises pour
soutenir l'économie française la vraie
question et se demander si il lui fallut
500 milliards si nous avions lu les
masques et si nous avions eu les tests
si nous avons eu des ddd des milliers de
lits de réanimation qui nous ont manqué
si la france en bref avec étaient mieux
préparés certainement cette crise
pourrait coûter moins cher donc tout ça
ça montre qu' il faut sortir de cette
politique qui jusqu'à présent en régie
la santé parce que cette politique nous
a emmenés dans le mur
alors oui on a envie de quoi mais lui il
va falloir qu'ils nous donnent des gages
qui nous montre des actes qui vont nous
laisser croire en fait et nous laissait
entendre que véritablement on refuse
vraiment ce qui a encadré jusqu'à
présent la santé que l'on donne une part
du pouvoir ce mot est peut-être dur mais
c'est celui ci qu'il faut une part du
pouvoir et d'organisation aux soignants
sur la santé une allocution
plutôt risqué pour le président ce soir
à deux semaines du second tour des
municipales la campagne électorale
commence effectivement officiellement ce
soir à minuit et à cause des conditions
sanitaires elle va durer
exceptionnellement trois longues
semaines
5000 communes sont concernées surtout
les grandes villes avec un parti
présidentiel plutôt mal parti pour ce
scrutin local emmanuel macron avait déjà
annoncé qu'il en tirerait toutes les
conséquences
un discours présidentiel qui était très
attendue par les forces de l'ordre alors
qu'ils sont traités de racistes ces
derniers jours est mise en cause dans
leurs techniques d'interpellation des
policiers français qui vous le voyez ont
de nouveau marquer leur colère hier soir
réunis devant l'arc
triomphe à paris ils ont chanté la
marseillaise et jeté à terre leurs
menottes il s'estime toujours lâchés par
leur ministre de l'intérieur écouter on
voit que là c'est de plus en plus
difficile de faire ce métier
donc on espère du soutien on espère de
soutien à la population qu'ils se
rendent compte un petit peu de ce qui se
passe et qu'elle ouvre les yeux et puis
quelle soit avec nous voilà que de
n'importe quelle couleur
lundi dernier il ya eu une
une cassure qui assure avec des propos
que les collègues aujourd'hui n'ont pas
n'ont pas accepté parce qu'ils ont
estimé qu'ils ont
on a généralisé le mot racisme on a on a
on a mis en doute leur professionnalisme
avec des techniques qu'on maîtrise
depuis des années
tout ça pour que pour que la nôtre calme
et la clameur publique tout ça parce
qu'une minorité dit que la police tu es
raciste et la police ne fait pas bien
sûr
il n'avait pas le droit de traiter les
effectifs comme elisa ce traité nous
cette lettre on en prend acte mais à
l'intérieur de ce fait les choses nous
conviennent pas
les techniques d'interpellation et la
technique d'étain d'étranglement dans
cette lettre il confiant toujours le
retrait qui parle de mise en place de
commissions mais on prend le problème à
l'envers
une manifestation qui s'est déroulée à
l'issue d'une mobilisation contre le
racisme
un peu plus tôt dans la journée quinze
mille personnes se sont rassemblées
place de la république avec quelques
tensions face aux forces de l'ordre une
mobilisation statique qui a été imposée
sur ordre de la préfecture de paris
vingt-et-une personnes ont été placées
en garde à vue
et puis sachez par ailleurs que la
préfecture de police a annoncé avoir
signalé à la justice pendant cette
manifestation est des propos antisémites
entendu au coeur de ce rassemblement
parisien et puis sachez que d'autres
manifestations se sont déroulées dans le
même temps à travers toute la france
comme à nantes à lille ou encore à
marseille regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
bonus tracks bal trad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prévoyez à présent les réactions de la
classe politique suite à ces
manifestations
christophe castaner qui a aussi remercié
les forces de l'ordre écoutez
reconnaissance et indéfectible soutien
en forces de l'ordre prises pour cibles
je salue l'engagement et le
professionnalisme avec lesquels elles
ont sécurisé est partout en france les
manifestations de ce jour je soutiens ce
qui nous protège policiers gendarmes
pompiers et souhaite un prompt
rétablissement aux forces de l'ordre
blessés dans l'exercice de leur mission
lors des manifestations sans forces de
l'ordre pas de sécurité pas de liberté
pas de fraternité
il faut entendre les plus jeunes ces
derniers mois ils ont placé au premier
rang le péril climatique
il réveille aujourd'hui les consciences
sur le poison du racisme jamais éradiqué
il les appelle la république à tenir ses
promesses
ils sont l'authentic république en
marche malgré les provoquent de
l'allemand une foule pacifique massive
résolu à montrer que la france qu'on
aime celle de la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité et d'état république
merci au comité la vérité pour adama
pour cette initiative
son calme son sens politique voilà le
résultat de l'inaction et de la lâcheté
du pouvoir face aux indigéniste et à
l'extrême gauche anti flics la violence
les émeutes le saccage en plein paris il
n'y a plus aucune autorité de l'état
honte au gouvernement des milliers de
personnes manifestent illégalement sans
interpellation et 12 personnes qui
déploient une banderole contre le
racisme anti blancs sont arrêtés ce deux
poids deux mesures est insupportable
tous les racismes sont condamnables
les policiers manifestent vendredi sur
les champs on empêche les antiracistes
de justice pour adama de défiler et on
transforme leur manif en rassemblement
avec le massage et les violences
habituelles
rien ne change ce qui est bon pour les
uns ne l'est pas pour les autres
trois semaines après le décès de georges
floyd aux etats unis un afro-américain
décède sous les balles de la police à
atlanta il a été mortellement blessé la
nuit dernière alors qu'il tentait
d'échapper à un contrôle des autorités
l'homme en état d'ébriété se serait
emparé du taser d'un des policiers avant
de prendre la fuite
l'agent responsable du tir a été renvoyé
le deuxième relégué à des tâches
administratives
la cheffe de la police d'atlanta a
présenté sa démission à des manifestants
qui vous le voyez ont mis le feu au
restaurant devant lequel s'est déroulée
cette interpellation mortels
retour sur ces dernières semaines
d'agitation aux états unis où donald
trump a tenté de maintenir la loi et
l'ordre
une doctrine critiqué par l'opposition
démocrate
répertoire
[Musique]
il a été suggéré de rebaptiser jusqu'à
10 de nos bases militaires légendaires
comme ford bragg en caroline du nord
fort hood au texas ford benning en
géorgie etc
ces bases monumentale et très puissantes
sont désormais partie d'un grand
patrimoine américain d'une histoire de
victoires et de liberté les etats unis
d'amérique ont formé déployer nos héros
sur ses terres sacrées et ont remporté
deux guerres mondiales
par conséquent mon administration
n'envisagera même pas de renommer ses
magnifiques et légendaire installations
militaires
notre histoire en tant que plus grande
nation du monde ne sera pas altérée
respecter nos militaires
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le peuple américain c'est
que ces noms doivent disparaître ces
noms sont des suprémacistes blancs qui
ont dit des choses terribles sur notre
pays plus de cent ans après la seconde
guerre mondiale certains de ces noms ont
été donnés à ses bases
et si vous écoutez qui ils sont et ce
qu'ils ont dit et que vous demandez au
président d'expliquer pourquoi une base
devrait être nommé en leur honneur
il semble être la seule personne qui ne
comprend pas ici l'épreuve chinoise
inquiète
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
au liban la mobilisation contre le
pouvoir se poursuit plusieurs centaines
de personnes se sont réunies dans les
rues des principales villes du pays des
libanais confrontés à la chute de leur
monnaie face au dollar
il dénonce également une action du
gouvernement face à l'aggravation de
cette crise économique dans la soirée
hassan diab a le premier ministre a
tenté de d'apaiser la situation il a
dénoncé également des tentatives de
déstabilisation de l'état écouter une
fois de plus une tentative de coup
d'état échoué toutes les réunions
secrètes et connus ont échoué c'est ici
que se trouve la vérité sur le plan de
la manipulation du taux de change du
dollar américain par rapport à la livre
libanaise et c'est ici que se trouvent
les secrets de la nuit du coup d'état
sur le soulèvement du 17 octobre le coup
d'état n'était pas contre le
gouvernement comme la lutte contre la
corruption est très féroce car les
corrompus ne se rendent pas
volontairement mais je vous promets que
le changement viendra inévitablement
même s'il essaie de le bloquer et voyez
à présent l'analyse de charbel nahas il
est économiste et ancien ministre du
travail au niveau des la crise
humanitaire dans le sens d'une famine et
cetera bon évidemment c'est paul monde
mais je crains fort qu'avant d'arriver
avec lise l'humanitaire et asseoir une
crise sécuritaire et une hémorragie des
migrations et l'appauvrissement et a
complètement fait évaporer les revenus
mais aussi les pagnes avec des habitudes
de vie de consommation qui ont duré
tellement longtemps vont rendre
l'adaptation excessivement difficile et
par conséquent les deux soupapes qui se
présente c'est essentiellement une
émigration massive
un exode et où l'un pouvant appuyer
l'autre des troubles sécuritaires
sérieux et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité sur notre
antenne on se retrouve dans 30 minutes
rester avec nous
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports vont nous devons
instaurer aux êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente quoi dire une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
tous les secteurs de la culture sont
sont touchés la musique le cinéma le
théâtre elle les musées avec trois mois
de